this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealthfront is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than ten asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance
now normally when I have a sponsor on
this show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
Tim this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design I recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one New York Times best seller
I've also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free $99 upgrade on your first design so
check it out 99 designs dot-com forward
slash Tim
hello my gorgeous little groundhogs this
is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show this is
not a long-form interview in fact it is
a bite-sized morsel for your brain and
for your life and this is an excerpt
from my favorite writing of all time
that I review at least once a quarter
the letters to Luke alias moral letters
to Luke Aeolus by Seneca the younger
roughly 2,000 years old and this letter
is number 22 on the futility of halfway
measures and as usual Seneca takes a
little time and is preamble to get
warmed up that is this style kind of
feeling out the opponent ie the
recipient of his letter as if in a
boxing match and then he jumps right
into it and there's some really valuable
takeaways here
my favorite portion begins with hence
men leave such advantages as these with
reluctance and it is a gem I really
encourage you to listen to this over and
over again particularly the passages
beginning with hence men leave such
advantages as these with reluctance and
you can find all of these letters I
think they're about one hundred and
twenty and three volumes as part of my
book club if you're interested the Tao
of Seneca is the compilation and I
created it because I wanted to listen to
this an audio and couldn't find it and
all of that and more can be found at
audible.com forward slash Tim's books so
please enjoy Seneca on the futility of
halfway measures
letter 22 on the futility of halfway
measures you understand by this time
that you must withdraw yourself from
those showy and depraved pursuits but
you still wish to know how this may be
accomplished there are certain things
which can be pointed out only by someone
who is present the physician cannot
prescribe by letter the proper time for
eating or bathing he must feel the pulse
there is an old adage about gladiators
that they plan their fight in the ring
as they intently watch something in the
adversaries glance some movement of his
hand even some slight bending of his
body gives a warning we can formulate
general rules and commit them to writing
as to what is usually done or ought to
be done such advice may be given not
only to our absent friends but also to
succeeding generations in regard however
to that second question when or how your
plan is to be carried out
no one will advise at long range we must
take counsel in the presence of the
actual situation you must be not only
present in the body but watchful in mind
if you would avail yourself of the
fleeting opportunity accordingly look
about you for the opportunity if you see
it grasp it and with all your energy and
with all your strengths devote yourself
to this task to rid yourself of those
business duties now listen carefully to
the opinion which I shall offer it is my
opinion that you should withdraw either
from that kind of existence or else from
existence all together but i likewise
maintain that you should take a gentle
path that you may loosen rather than cut
the knot which you have bungled so badly
and tying provided that if there shall
be no other way of loosening it you may
actually cut it
no man is so faint hardened that he
would rather hang in suspense forever
then drop once for all
meanwhile and this is of first
importance do not hamper yourself be
content with the business into which you
have lowered yourself or as you prefer
to have people think have tumbled there
is no reason why you should be
struggling on to something further if
you do you will lose all grounds of
excuse and men will see that it was not
a tumble the usual explanation which men
offer is wrong I was compelled to do it
suppose it was against my will I had to
do it but no one is compelled to pursue
prosperity at top speed it means
something to call a halt even if one
does not offer resistance instead of
pressing eagerly after favoring fortune
shall you then be put out with me if I
not only come to advise you but also
called in others to advise you wiser
heads than my own men before whom I am
want to lay any problem upon which I am
pondering read the letter of Epicurus
which appears on this matter it is
addressed to ito - the writer asks him
to hasten as fast as he can and be to
retreat before some stronger influence
comes between and takes from him the
Liberty to withdraw but he also adds
that one should attempt nothing except
at the time when it can be attempted
suitably and seasonably then when the
long-sought occasion comes let him be up
and doing
Epicurus forbids us to doze when we are
meditating escape he bids us hope for a
safe release from even the hardest
trials provided that we are not in too
great a hurry before the time nor to
dilatory when the time arrives now I
suppose you are looking for a stoic
motto also there is really no reason why
anyone should slander that school to you
on the ground of its rashness as a
matter of fact it's caution is greater
than its courage you are perhaps
expecting the sect to utter such words
as these
it is based to flinch under a burden
wrestle with the duties which you have
once undertaken no man is brave and
earnest if he avoids danger if his
spirit does not grow with the very
difficulty of his task words like these
will indeed be spoken to you if only
your perseverance shall have an object
that is worthwhile if only you will not
have to do or to suffer anything
unworthy of a good man besides a good
man will not waste himself upon mean and
discreditable work or be busy merely for
the sake of being busy neither will he
as you imagine become so involved in
ambitious schemes that he will have
continually to endure their urban flow
nay when he sees the dangers
uncertainties and hazards in which he
was formerly tossed about he will
withdraw not turning his back to the foe
but falling back little by little to a
safe position from business however my
dear Luke Elias it is easy to escape if
only you will despise the rewards of
business but we are held back and kept
from escaping by thoughts like these
what then shall I leave behind me these
great prospects shall I depart at the
very time of harvest shall I have no
slaves at my side no retinue for my
litter no crowd in my reception room
hence men leave such advantages as these
with reluctance they love the reward of
their hardships but cursed the hardships
themselves men complain about their
ambitions as they complain about their
mistresses in other words if you
penetrate their real feelings you will
find not hatred but bickering search the
minds of those who cried down what they
have desired who talk about escaping
from things which they are unable to do
without you will comprehend that they
are lingering of their own free will in
a situation which they declare they find
it hard and wretched to endure it is so
bye dear Luke Elias
there are a few men whom slavery holds
fast but there are many more who old
fast
to slavery if however you intend to be
rid of this slavery if freedom is
genuinely pleasing in your eyes and if
you seek counsel for this one purpose
that you may have the good fortune to
accomplish this purpose without
perpetual annoyance how can the whole
company of stoic thinkers fail to
approve your course Zeno
Chrissa boosts and all their kind will
give you advice that is temperate
honorable and suitable but if you keep
turning round and looking about in order
to see how much you may carry away with
you and how much money you may keep to
equip yourself for the life of leisure
you will never find a way out no man can
swim ashore and take his baggage with
him rise to a higher life with the favor
of the gods but let it not be favor of
such a kind as the gods give to men when
with kind and genial faces they bestow
magnificent ills justified in so doing
by the one fact that the things which
irritate and torture have been bestowed
in answer to prayer I was just putting
the seal upon this letter but it must be
broken again in order that it may go to
you with its customary contribution
bearing with it some noble word and lo
here is one that occurs to my mind I do
not know whether its truth or its
nobility of utterance is the greater
spoken by whom you ask by Epicurus for I
am still appropriating other men's
belongings the words are
everyone goes out of life just as if he
had but lately entered it take anyone
off his guard young old or middle-aged
you will find that all are equally
afraid of death and equally ignorant of
life no one has anything finished
because we have kept putting off into
the future all our undertakings no
thought and the quotation given above
pleases me more than that it taunts old
men with being infants no one he says
leave this world in a different manner
from one who has just been born that is
not true for we are worse when we die
than when we were born but it is our
fault and not that of nature nature
should scold us saying what does this
mean I brought you into the world
without desires or fears free from
superstition treachery and the other
curses go forth as you were when you
entered a man has caught the message of
wisdom if he can die as free from care
as he was at birth but as it is we are
all aflutter at the approach of the
dreaded end our courage fails us our
cheeks blanch our tears fall though they
are unavailing but what is baser than to
fret at the very threshold of peace
the reason however is that we are
stripped of all our goods
we have jettisoned our cargo of life and
are in distress for no part of it has
been packed in the hold it has all been
heaved overboard and has drifted away
men do not care how nobly they live but
only how long although it is within the
reach of every man to live nobly but
within no man's power to live long
farewell hey guys this is Tim again just
a few more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet Friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday the vet provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design I recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I'd use
them for many years I use them to create
book cover prototypes for the 4-hour
body which went on to become a number
one York Times bestseller
I've also use them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs dot-com fold /
Tim and right now you can get a free 9
million dollar upgrade on your first
design so check it out 99 designs com
forward slash tips
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront
is a massively disruptive in a good way
set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealthtrack so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint and little things that you may
or may not be familiar with like
automatic tax loss harvesting
rebalancing your portfolio across more
than 10 asset classes and dividend
reinvestment add up to very large
amounts of money over longer periods of
time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show is because I use them and recommend
them in this case it's a little
different I don't use wealthfront yet
because I'm not allowed to here's the
deal they wanted to sponsor this podcast
but because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been
so impressed by wealthfront that I've
invested a significant amount of my own
money at least for me in the team and
the company itself so I am an investor
and hope to soon use it as a client now
back to the recommendation as a Tim
Ferriss show listener
you'll get fifteen thousand dollars
managed for free if you decide to open
an account but just start with seeing
the portfolio that they would suggest
for you take two minutes fill out their
questionnaire at wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim it's fast it's free
there's no downside that I can think of
just take a look see what portfolio they
would create for you and you can use
that information however you want
wealthfront comm forward slash Tim and
until next time thank you for listening
you